my I fell asleep on my arm you're making
my own sweat TIFF can you imagine a
world where you wake up you can see
clearly that's the world I would love to
live in and I will tomorrow tomorrow
morning I will be getting LASIK I could
finally see I'll be singing I can see
clearly now the rain is gone you guys I
know what LASIK is it's a eye surgery
that's correct your vision I was very
scared and very nervous I mean it's
scary you're I was gonna get cut open
and then there's gonna be laser you name
it oh my gosh it's a really scary
feeling but this little fact is what
really convinced me to get LASIK and not
be scared is the fact that it's
virtually impossible for you to go blind
with LASIK so let's use these ever again
just fashion smash them tomorrow
no guys you're gonna have to see me like
this and you because I can't wear makeup
for two weeks after my procedure that's
gonna be kind of weird you're gonna see
a lot of this I don't mind I actually
like you without anything on your face
this face right here that that's the
face of home and as as Dory from Finding
Nemo we'll put it I look at you and I'm
home two weeks of being a home
yeah that's not the case for me though
we film taking news once a week that's
gonna be 2jk new sessions and I won't be
able to have any makeup on it's gonna be
kind of weird it's fine it's not a big
deal
but when you're in front of the camera a
lot and like you're filming a show it's
like I mean you should look presentable
and put some makeup on really here nah I
don't know man it's midnight and we're
about to go to sleep and I think it's
it's starting to realize what's about to
happen tomorrow
how you feeling singing it man my
eyeball hot it's kind of scary actually
but I mean I know I know I'm gonna be
okay it's just there's gonna be open
like open like they're actually gonna
cut my eyeballs open I gotta scary
especially if it's only a nightmare yeah
yeah your game Valerius yeah
morning so now it's Saturday morning my
surgery is at 9:45 getting more real
than it was last night
take the closer of getting to it the
more nervous I'm getting I just keep
thinking of it opening my eyeballs kind
of crazy and weird there's on bumpy as
rocket star sorry guys
hey what are you guys doing with the
camera okay that's how you can tell I'm
really nervous because now I'm just
being really weird what kind of meds no
it doesn't Mexican do you feel more
Mexican there
can be more and more excited for ten
mouths shrugs excited yeah heart
shattered leg nervous
you want to panic
the excited nervous levels
this is nervous as excited for so like
this now it's getting more like the most
important thing I'm doing for her today
is to drive her home second most
important thing when she gets cold
jacket back what's the track yeah okay
no the Sun made it warm is pretty warm
outside I mean I mean it was totally
meeting me yeah let me ask you this this
is a pretty big moment for you to
capture on video what is the number one
most important thing to capture free in
your life if I could only do one then it
would be the birth of my next child like
full glory oh oh
I mean of what I'm okay guys good good
alright that I'm like I wish I had
captured that in film with Isaac well
we'll start with this process or this
procedure and we'll work our way up to
that okay from LASIK to getting a face
cream yep that's the natural progression
of like a visit but it sure feels like
his home prison with R in a medical
environment she's the subject of
operation I'm just I'm just a guy off to
the side like you can do a baby
he's breathe in breathe out
yeah see it's good practice this is good
practice so LASIK was a good step
forward you can't read anything on that
line it says emergency and so Harriet
emergency evacuation plan IQ laser
vision one eight seven two five the last
meeting
so the procedure because I'm gonna meet
with dr. Lin now a lot of people scared
by surgery
you're one of the great people LASIK is
not like other eye surgeries where you
could go by in fact in the US there's
never been any important cases of
blindness from LASIK when you go in
there what you want to do is relax all
your facial muscles pretend you're on
drugs
yeah so now let me do everything the
best line of your doctor has ever done
to me yeah Patricia patients ready
you
I was like you know what you were not
talking I know you're nervous but you
did perfectly you're my top 1% okay all
right bye take care good bye good doctor
like I do that after the first I was
done I felt like I let you rest for a
little bit I'll ask a question later
oh you're all set I'm gonna help you out
but open your eyes
let's see where you're going
this probably might kind of hurt your
eyes huh this side
yeah close your eyes yes oh oh that's
not to say yes I'm doing my job didn't
do my job at all okay yeah I really get
way too great opening the door nice
we'll be home very soon oh my god you
crazy why am I getting emotional with
the help I'm very emotional
oh man I'm a close by it hahaha I'm
starting to cry get it so crazy I can
see it's so crazy
why are you staring at kicking are you
great I'm happy to see you yeah I'm
really happy so happy thank you thank
you
thank you guys the key see I think I
almost hope doing better though
he's all mommies awake Hina mummy
how was your sleep out of your eyes feel
now ah stop it I was like forever oh my
gosh I feel like is so drugged up him
like this slumber this mystic really
brave you gotta go relate okay
where we going now going to my post-op
appointment
hey where'd you go
that's a hell so we're here and
everything so Chris cool man it is so
cool
here's a little number that I want you
to dedicate to all the fans out there I
could see clearly no are you going with
this ready yeah
I can clearly now the rain is gone no
wait hold on a tubular okay clearly now
I got LASIK done thing such a big baby
it's not even that bad [ __ ] good night
good night